foreign
[Music]
so hidden pictures by Jason rekulak
hopefully I'm pronouncing that correctly
this is a supernatural Thriller that was
released uh quite recently in May of
2023 and it kind of seemed to be one of
those books that kind of had the horror
and Thriller Community like all abuzz a
lot of people were talking about it and
it actually ended up winning the 2022
Goodreads Choice Award in the horror
category
um I will admit though that I didn't
know about any of that when I just kind
of randomly came across it when I was
scrolling through my Kindle unlimited
suggestions uh all that happened was
like I thought the title and the cover
design you know sort of struck me as
potentially interesting so I checked it
out and read it and I actually ended up
plowing through the entire book in like
a single day and it's not short it's
like 372 pages but I was like actually
compelled to finish it like over the
course of a single day
so I will say um it's a pretty like
simple uh compelling read it's quite
well written
um and does have some twists and turns
that I didn't predict uh For Better or
For Worse
um and I will say that it's use of
illustrations there are illustrations in
there uh done by two different guys will
still I think is how you pronounce his
last name I again I'm apologizing if I
mess that up and uh Doogie Horner they
did the um the illustrations in there so
that is kind of like a cool aspect of it
as well
um and the thing is like I actually kind
of I guess I enjoyed it while I was
reading it but I'm gonna say writer they
get a couple things one it's not
strictly a horror novel uh it's kind of
more like a mystery or a thriller with
Supernatural elements so no that going
into it two gonna say I had some pretty
big issues with the messaging let's call
it that
um it does sort of Wallop you upside the
head with it uh mostly toward the end
although there's some kind of problem
dramatic [__] in the beginning of it too
not gonna lie about that also I kind of
found that some of the plot twists
toward the end were like kind of uh
ludicrous or kind of like came out of
left field a little bit and I'm gonna
say too that the more I thought about
the book like days afterward like kind
of the more it pissed me off you know
like the more I thought about it I'll
get more into that a bit later though
because talking about the issues that I
had with it um will definitely
necessitate some spoilers so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna put a spoiler
alert like right here at the very
beginning and I'll also put one like
before I start talking about the end of
the book before I start talking about
like kind of the issues that I had with
it okay but it's like here's a spoiler
alert just in case so this is actually
Jason regulak's second novel um his
first one which is called The Impossible
Fortress was published in 2017 and was
actually shortlisted for an Edgar award
um I will also know I thought this was
kind of interesting that recollect was
also the publisher of Quark books for a
long time uh and Quirk books was
actually responsible for releasing some
pretty modern horror favor Ritz I guess
you would call them
um Miss Peregrine's Home for Peculiar
Children which big hit like uh by Ransom
rigs which I think was made into a film
or a series uh Pride and Prejudice and
Zombies that was like a big hit also
Seth Graham Smith and um Quirk books
also released a lot of Grady Hendrix
books as well and as you guys know I'm a
big fan of Grady Hendrix so I thought
that was pretty interesting
so this particular book hidden pictures
uh this is actually told from the
perspective of a 21 year old woman whose
name is Mallory Quinn
and she's sort of been recently working
hard to put her mess of a life back
together I guess so A couple of years
back uh she was like a track star and
she had a running scholarship and this
bright future ahead of her but then one
day she's driving a car and she gets
into an accident that wasn't really her
fault uh in which her little sister Beth
was killed
Mallory was also horribly injured ended
up getting addicted to painkillers and
then eventually moved on to like the
harder stuff like heroin and at times
was homeless resorted to you know
prostitution in order to pay for the
drugs and [__] like that
so you know so like I said she's she's
seen some [__] she's been through some
[__] now unsurprisingly her and her
mother uh became estranged after that
point because she kind of fell off the
grid a little bit however at the
beginning of the story uh Mallory has
successfully gone through a rehab
program and has been sober for 18 months
now her sponsor his name is Russell he's
able to give her a lead on what seems
like the perfect job for her right um
she's supposed to be like a live-in
nanny over the summer for this very
wealthy couple who had this adorable son
now although you would think that a
family that had the means to hire a
nanny for their kid in the first place
uh would actually have their pick of
candidates and wouldn't have to go with
their recovering drug addict you know
what I mean
it turns out that the mom of the couple
whose name is Caroline is a psychiatrist
and she works with veterans with PTSD
and former addicts and things like that
so she's very understanding uh toward
Mallory's struggles and you know is
seemingly happy to help her out
um the dad whose name is Ted he seems a
lot more reluctant but Caroline tells
Mallory oh I'll be able to talk him into
it and she ends up doing exactly that so
the couple eventually allows Mallory to
move into this kind of small but really
nicely renovated guest house that they
have on the property and they pretty
much immediately make her feel like
she's part of the family so it seems
like great like the perfect situation
right also the kid who she's watching is
this little five-year-old adorable
moppet named Teddy and he's kind of the
the kind of child that probably any
parent would kill for right he's very
smart he's very curious he's very well
behaved uh you know does what he's told
he's very funny he's very Embassy
um and Mallory like adores him
immediately and Teddy also seems to
adore her right back now Teddy's parents
are a little bit
overprotective I guess I mean it's not
like way crazy or anything like that but
they do give Mallory a list of house
rules for dealing with the kid which I
mean seems like a pretty reasonable
thing for parents to do like for a nanny
you know what I mean but right here
right here was where I first started
having a little bit of an issue with the
book
so it's made very very clear that Ted
and Caroline the parents are atheists
which fine I'm an atheist too we'll get
into that but these seem to be the type
of militant atheists that really mostly
only exist in the very vivid
imaginations of kind of maybe certain
types of you know fundamentalists or
like you know right-wing religious type
of people you know what I mean like
right there on the house rules list that
they give her they pretty much say that
they are so strictly a science-based
household that they don't celebrate
Christmas and they don't even allow
anyone to say God bless you to their kid
when he sneezes
so I'm reading this and I'm like hmm
okay I I consider myself quite a firm
atheist okay and I have been since I was
old enough to have any kind of opinion
on the matter no my parents did not
raise me that way they were vaguely
religious themselves I wasn't brought up
in a particular religion but my parents
like believed in God and everything like
that I just kind of figured it out on my
own when I was younger you know what I
mean and I have never in my over 50
years of life met another atheist who
was even a little bit offended by
someone saying God bless you to them
when they sneeze or to their kids or
anything like that or by something
somebody wishing them and their kids
Merry Christmas or [__] like that
um in fact I don't think I've ever met
another atheist who didn't celebrate
Christmas or some kind of like Christmas
equivalent I mean it's a fun winter
holiday it has Pagan Roots anyway
um so you know I kind of feel like you'd
have to be like a real Scrooge to like
not want to get into that action you
know what I mean it's like it's like
seriously I don't believe in God one
tiny Iota and I [__] love Christmas
like not as much as I love Halloween I
will admit that but I mean Christmas is
pretty rad right now I'm not saying that
there aren't these real cranky militant
holiday hating atheists out there
somewhere but in my experience it's not
super common uh they're extreme outliers
outliers
so when I read this part of the thing I
was just kind of like oh [__] like my
little antennas are going up like oh
[__] is this gonna be like some [__]
religious right-wing propaganda or some
kind of [__] like that and this
impression was only strengthened as I
kind of went on because Ted and Caroline
um while initially very welcoming and
they seem really nice to Mallory they're
also portrayed as very condescending
very Superior and they kind of have some
other
you know maybe what some people would
call like woke leftist kind of Trades
like oh they're being super Vigilant
about eating organic food staying away
from red meat not letting Teddy watch TV
or use a tab like limiting his screen
time stuff like that and there was some
other stuff later on that kind of
hammered this home like even more
egregiously but I'll get to that in a
little bit now by contrast Mallory is
described as a Christian she wears a
cross her sponsor is a preacher and she
says early on you know she gave her life
to Jesus Christ in rehab and all of that
and there's also like a little bit it's
not even a subplot because it's not
super gone into but she tries at least
she goes to different churches in the
area where she moves to never really
settles on one blade blah now I will
note that her religiosity in the story
is not nearly as overt as Ted and
Caroline's atheism is but that's kind of
another reason that I started to get
suspicious of the author's motives
because the fact that Mallory is a
Christian she's apparently allowed to be
presented as flawed but also
multi-dimensional but evidently the
author thought it would be okay to show
the atheists as these just cartoonish
like straw man stereotype so I started
to get a little bit like hmm all right I
kind of see where this is going you know
what I'm saying so but I mean okay fine
so I was just rolling my eyes at this
like a little bit
um you know thinking to myself well you
know maybe this author has never really
met any real atheists remember maybe
he's never met any real liberals or
vegetarians or whatever
um and or was trying to like push a
particular agenda which okay I wasn't
really all that mad about it at first
because even though it's very laughably
heavy-handed for sure
um Ted and Caroline at first seemed like
okay people otherwise so I kind of like
let it slide because here's the thing
like I don't have to agree with
everything the author or the characters
think or do like in order to enjoy a
story you know what I mean I'm kind of a
tolerant [__] like that I mean at least
up to a point you know what I'm saying
but
I will say that at this point I was
starting to get that feeling like I got
when I started reading that terrible
Frank Peretti Bigfoot book which I think
is called Monster and then had to like
nope out when it just turned into a
straight up creationist screed you know
what I mean I so I was kind of I was
kind of afraid it was going to go in
that direction you know what I mean so
back to the story so Teddy the kid uh he
really likes to draw uh and most of the
stuff he draws is just you know normal
kid stuff people animals houses Happy
Sons [__] like that
um Teddy also has a purported imaginary
friend who he calls Anya
um and sometimes he puts Anya into his
drawings and she's a little bit creepy
looking to say the least uh Teddy's
parents being all about science you know
with a capital S they allow him to have
this imaginary friend because you know
it's a normal part of growing up and all
that but they do tell him in no
uncertain terms that Anya is not real
Mallory though who is you know seen as
more spiritual and all of that starts to
believe that maybe Anya is actually real
uh as not only does Teddy do drawings of
her which become increasingly disturbing
like somebody being dragged Through the
Woods by their hair and like buried in a
shallow grave [__] like that but Mallory
also hears Teddy seemingly having a
one-sided conversation with somebody in
his room like when he's supposedly in
there by himself
now Mallory asks around
and finds out that there's a very
well-known story around this
neighborhood that has to do with the
very guest house that she's living in
so back in the day so the story goes
there was a woman named Annie and she
was the artist niece of a guy who owned
the property
and she disappeared from the house
and left behind nothing but just an
alarming amount of blood just like
splatter all over the walls now her body
was never found and everybody presumed
that she'd been murdered so like
everybody in town knows this story some
people think it's just an urban legend
because it happened a long time ago but
pretty much everybody in this kind of
like wealthy neighborhood has heard it
you know now another like unrelated
family had lived on the property for
like decades before Ted and Caroline
moved there and they used the guest
house as like a storage shed and they
also apparently never complained about
any paranormal activity or anything at
least as far as anybody knows but
Mallory
along with this flaky neighbor lady
named Mitzi who makes her living as a
medium and is also a flaming racist so
there's that they believe that when Ted
and Caroline renovated the guest house
that they stirred up Annie's spirit and
that Annie is using Teddy's drawings to
like communicate try to communicate to
them like what happened to her
um you know they figure oh well the name
Annie is pretty close to Anya you know
the imaginary friend and once Teddy's
drawings start to become like way more
detailed and way more accomplished than
a five-year-old could draw Mallory
starts
um becoming convinced that this is
actually what's going on and she
actually later
even you know cements this even more
when she installs like a baby monitor in
Teddy's room and she sees what appears
to be him becoming like possessed or
having some kind of episode or seizure
or something like that and then drawing
stuff and then not remembering what he
drew like when he comes out of it so
Mallory and her love interest whose name
is Adrian um he's also religious he's
from like a the only Mexican family in
the neighborhood
um so he believes her and the two of
them try to arrange all of Teddy's
drawings into some kind of narrative
that makes sense to them but they're
having trouble figuring out what this
supposed ghost is trying to tell them
like they can't figure out like what the
symbolism or what the drawings mean you
know what I mean now Mitzi the neighbor
she organizes this Ouija board session
uh and it seems to work but produces
what appears to be just like a bunch of
gibberish you know what I mean so as the
investigation goes on
it starts to become obvious that
whatever this thing is that's
communicating through Teddy's drawings
it's not exactly what it appears
and this All Leads up to this big
shocking twist which as I mentioned I'm
going to have to spoil in order to break
down what like what was so sort of like
galling about the End of This Book okay
so this is your second third fourth
whatever like spoiler spoiler warning
so it turns out
that Annie who is the artist niece who
was supposedly murdered in the guest
house with all blood and stuff like that
actually isn't dead at all she's still
alive
um she just eloped with a black man like
way back in the day and her shitty dad
faked her disappearance and supposed
murder to like cover up how ashamed he
was of that happening
so that whole plot thread was nothing
but a misdirection this is not Annie's
ghost Annie wasn't even murdered nothing
like that like the blood all that was
true but like she didn't die you know
what I mean her dad did that
the real villains of the piece of course
are those evil liberal atheists didn't
care why
okay so the ghost there is a ghost but
we find out that this ghost is actually
a woman named Margaret I guess is how
you pronounce her last name Margaret or
marget
who was a Hungarian immigrant who
Caroline used to see in the neighborhood
where they used to live like a couple of
years ago
so Ted and Caroline wanted kids but were
having trouble conceiving and Caroline
started to become more and more agitated
by this Market woman who had this
beautiful two-year-old daughter named
Flora that Caroline perceived that the
woman was neglecting whether she really
was or not we don't know because we only
have Caroline's word for it you know
what I'm saying so one day Caroline
comes across Margaret painting in a
clearing in the woods an evidently
Margaret was so focused on her painting
that she didn't notice when Flora
wandered off so Caroline you know feels
the need to swoop in and rescue the kid
and after Margaret tried to get her
daughter back Caroline
accidentally or on purpose killed her I
kind of feel like it was on purpose and
then roped her husband Ted into helping
her like bury the body
then the couple essentially kidnapped
Margaret's kid and started to raise her
as their own kid
now because Ted and Caroline are not
master criminals uh Margaret's body was
found pretty quickly which meant that
the couple had to kind of like make
themselves scarce moving to another town
with the kidnapped kid
um after like they spent a little while
in hiding so in order to allay suspicion
from their crime they also cut off
Flora's hair and put quote-unquote boy
clothes on her and started calling her
Teddy which would have been a kind of
like tired but not necessarily offensive
twist if the book didn't very explicitly
say that this meant the kid was trans
and I was just kind of like what
what like the fact they said that and
like and I was just like okay so okay I
apologize to anybody listening to this
because I'm sure all of you are
intelligent people and you already know
this but in case somebody else like
needs to hear this kidnapping a kid and
making them wear supposedly in other
gender's clothing to keep you from
getting caught that doesn't make that
kid trans I mean what the [__] are you
been talking about words mean things
dude I'm just saying clothes don't make
you transgender and I don't really I
don't I don't know I mean you're
basically all you're doing is you're
putting the kid in a disguise I mean
that has nothing to do with their gender
identity and it's like mystifying to me
that this was
allowed to pass muster I'm just like
that doesn't even make any sense and
what are you even talking about and it
wasn't just that it's like this whole
twist the way that it was framed in the
story
sounded as though the author was trying
to portray these evil vegetarian atheist
liberals as parents who were forcing
their kid into a gender identity they
didn't want and I was just kind of like
that's not what they're doing though and
it's just got I don't know it's just
something about the way that it was
written or the way it was framed was
like really
strange and it's just like I didn't
really get it it didn't help that there
was also because this was another thing
that happened a little bit earlier that
I was kind of like oh geez but
um it didn't help there was also a scene
like much earlier in the story where
Teddy asks Mallory like your standard
five-year-old question about like boy
parts and Girl cart parts and stuff like
that and then when Mallory tells
Caroline the mom about oh your kid asked
about this and it's like you know I
thought you'd want to talk to them about
it
Caroline comes home from the library or
the bookstore or whatever with a couple
of books for the kid
and the books are described as having
very explicit full color illustrations
of anal sex and cunnilingus in there and
I'm just like
um okay so again be coming from someone
you know being a very sex positive uh
you know atheist liberal myself I can
assure you that no parent of any
political persuasion is giving a
five-year-old a book showing that stuff
unless that parent is a complete [__]
psycho that should not have children I
mean and I was just like the whole time
I was reading it I was like is this
really what is this really what right
where's thick liberals do or like what
we want or like what we would give our
children or something like that she's
just [__] Christ and I'm just like uh
and I'm just like please crawl out of
your little rabbit holes and join us in
the real world it's like much nicer over
here it's like that doesn't happen and
it's like if that did happen we would be
like take those people's children away
immediately because that's [__] up
we're not doing that okay and it's just
like I just thought the whole thing was
[__] weird so yeah I mean so okay so
getting back to the actual plot of the
story so it's actually Margaret's ghost
so because there was a ghost so it was
actually Margaret's ghosts all along
making Teddy slash Flora draw these
pictures sure is to try to explain what
happened and the reason that she didn't
just come out and say like hey I'm
buried here or what or they killed me or
whatever was that she didn't really
speak much English so she was trying to
come across with the pictures which okay
makes total sense so now this is all
laid out in a very classic villain
monologue by Caroline and then after
that there are some very wildly
improbable plot developments like
Caroline and Ted also kill Mitzi by
making it look like she OD'd on heroin
and then they are planning on doing the
same thing to Mallory which again was
another reason why they picked somebody
that was a drug addict because I guess
they were planning on doing this the
whole time or whatever I don't really
know
and but then like when the whole thing
starts happening and Caroline has like I
said this whole villain thing where she
ties Mallory up and she's gonna like
shoot her up full of heroin and all this
other stuff but then apparently like Ted
has fallen in love with Mallory and then
wants to kill Caroline and then run off
with Mallory and like leave the kid
behind I mean it gets like pretty
batshit you know what I'm saying
um so again like spoiler alert but both
said and Caroline get killed uh and of
course you know steadfast Christian
awesome person Mallory saves the day and
she rescues Teddy slash flora and
eventually gets the kid returned to her
biological family so like I said overall
I mean this was a pretty interesting
mystery slash ghost story in the
beginning like despite some caveats like
a little bit of eye rolling that I had
in the beginning but other than that you
know I was having a good time with it
like it really it did Keep Me glued to
the page it went in directions I didn't
expect which like I said was kind of
cool but by the time that the final
reveals like the final twists came
around it was just like too much like
aside from all the stereotyping and the
kind of like weird propaganda and stuff
and which all just kind of gave me a
headache there was also the whole
straining credulity issue you know what
I mean like all the crazy [__] that
happened at the end I just couldn't buy
it like it seems
for example it seemed to me that it
would be pretty clear to a nanny that
this kid being passed off as a boy was
actually a girl I mean they went
swimming a bunch of times in the pool
like wouldn't Mallory have helped the
kid like bathe or get ready for bed or
something like that and be like hey
what's going on you know what I mean you
would think that
um and I mean besides that the whole
final third of the novel kind of asked
us to buy into the characters of Ted and
Caroline who had been perfectly normal
people up to this point like suddenly
turning into these wildly exaggerated
cackling super villains I mean it was
kind of ridiculous and I mean in
addition to kind of all the very
flagrantly like in your face anti-trans
stuff anti-atheist stuff there was also
kind of a little sprinkling of kind of
lazy racial stereotypes in there too
like there was one Asian character and
she was a quote-unquote pink-haired
weirdo who was really into anime and I
was like all right uh and then the one
Mexican family who were also very
wealthy and lived in the same
neighborhood as all the wealthy white
people were landscaper who mode all the
other people's laws so I was just kind
of like okay
um also the Mitzi character says [__]
about like all Mexicans being illegals
and rapists and I'm pretty sure that
we're supposed to like her especially
because she calls out Ted and Caroline
for like how elitist and like
hoity-toity they are so it's like and
then we're supposed to like feel bad
like when she gets murdered at the end
and stuff like that it was just it was
very very weird it was just the whole
tone of it was just very very weird
there was also this weird thing and this
is also like stated outright that when
Mallory talks about her past and about
her family and stuff it's it's very it
stated very flagrantly that Mallory's
mom couldn't help her with her addiction
problems because she was fat like that
was the reason that she couldn't help
her with her addiction problems and I
was just like
are you meaning because she has a food
addiction so she's kind of I don't know
it just seemed like that was the only
reason why she was fat and that's like
basically how that was how it was laid
out
um and then like at the end of the book
like Mallory finds out that her mom oh
her mom started exercising and lost some
weight and so then Mallory decides she's
gonna re-establish a relationship with
her because you know I don't know
Fitness is Next to Godliness or
something like that so it was like you
know not great all around there was a
lot of that kind of like stuff in there
where I was just like oh geez you know
what I mean I was just kind of like
rolling my eyes the whole time so I mean
to be fair
this was like I said overall it's
largely a solid it's not super original
concept but it's a pretty solid concept
and it's very decently written it's a
good suspense story it has Supernatural
elements
um the illustrations were really cool
and really added a lot to the story I
really really liked the illustration
aspect of it
um you know because it did kind of play
into the story like and they weren't
just in there you know just to be in
there you know I mean they did actually
have something to do with the plot but I
mean it's just kind of like this whole
blatant
you know stereotyping and fear-mongering
it just it got pretty uh tiresome and
the whole so the whole thing just kind
of ended up leaving a bad taste in my
mouth
um you know it's like there's a really
intriguing mystery in here behind all of
this unnecessary political dog whistling
that was going on in it
um but you know it's just kind of a
shame that maybe the author couldn't
keep his like weird agenda to himself
and just tell the story without having
to add all of this stuff in there I
don't know it just seemed too blatant to
be like just simple ignorance or
anything like that so I'm not really
sure if he believes all of this stupid
[__] that's in this book like all of the
stupid weird stereotypes and [__] like
that but it's kind of not cute
um and a lot of the attitudes in here
like actually you know the attitudes in
here can like do real harm to real
people so I was just kind of like well
yeah I don't love it I mean there is
absolutely a market for this sort of
thing um you know I mentioned Frank
Peretti earlier which is kind of more on
the super religious end because he
doesn't like a lot of creationist kind
of stuff and all that I don't really
love that either but um you know if
there's a market for it but but it's not
me obviously I mean like I said it's a
it's a good concept it was a good story
I kind of like you know enjoyed it I
wanted to see where it was going I
didn't dnf it or anything like that but
it's just it started like piling up and
then it's just started like pissing me
off after a while and then like the more
like after I finished it like the more I
thought about it like over the ensuing
days I was like ah yes yeah so it was
just kind of like that but you know if
that's your bag find it's you know a lot
of people did really seem to like it and
didn't
um didn't really notice that or it
didn't bother them or something like
that but there I did notice that there
was a significant portion of the reviews
that also noticed that kind of stuff and
we're like bro that's not that's not
cool or that's not cute or whatever and
it's just and they didn't really love it
either
so you know but so your mileage may vary
it may not bother you and that's you
know and that's totally fine so if you
want to read a lot like I said it won a
lot of awards it got a lot of good
reviews so you know it's it's all up to
you whether you want to read it or not I
didn't love it but you know what I mean
you might have a different opinion and
that's just how the world works you know
what I mean so yeah that will do it for
this tomes of Terror book review hope
you guys enjoyed it please remember like
share subscribe and all of that business
and I will see you guys again on the
next one bye